có người của khăn cần phải quán mà mục tiêu là mình phải lại nhiều.
Hay làm mình của cần phải ra nọc khi mà mình đã có một cái quy đặc quyết xai.
Đầu với những cái đặc phòng nghiệm, thì mình đối với nguồn và nên soch, chuyến trị quyết.
Rồi mới yếu tổ như thế là mất thời gian.
Hãy lưỡi là mình ăn quan hướng thì mình đưa thời gian tư.
Cái thứ 3 là đối với một số thiết nhỏ.
Đưa lưỡi là một phải trở một thái.
Nếu mà em từ lợi tư của phía quái phép máym,
thông bộ sẽ không trái.
Năm, bài, mười, của phía, chỉ tà ba mẹ của bố rất khó.
Mình mà nếu mà em bỏ một trở, chỉ tà bộ mời ghi vào tư.
Em vẫn có thể bộ được tình đấy.
Chà như thế, có thể hớt thì tình sẽ, tất cả những hướng và ngọt.
Mình mà cái việc trở ra rất, cường truyên.
Bỏ cái cả những hợi có nhiều khi nghiệp.
Mình tà bựng xài.
Bởi vì là xài hàng này,
chỉ có điều là khi mà xài.
Mình chỉ cần xa nịt gần là nếu mà
mình xài, mình mất bảo nếu vẫn được nếu như bảo nếu.
Tất là, bài rất là những gì dựng các thích bà.
Bà mình cũng sự thích bà thích bà đó.
Mình mà cái thái là mình lương phá ra.
Mình tà cơ của bệnh cái thứ li này.
Giảm ảm ả.
Mình muốn biết nóng quảy thì là máy thì nóng.
Ừ, sấu lần nữa.
Bạn nào là đúng định nóng quảy thì biết là mình đã không mất.
Hám chẳng trở mệnh chậu.
Làm thì bạn thân dấy làm một cái thích kiếm bà,
mình nên thả lọc cái thích bà.
Để mình mọ quảy thì tự kiếm vào đàn hoa người món.
Ừ, là nó mẹ lần cái câu sẩm.
Tất cả những khoan điều của hành của anh cũng là những xài rất nhiều mà.